[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there are a lot of reasons to like
justin tucker
he's uh going to go into the hall of
fame he's uh
clutch and um he's a winner he's got
great hair
and he's also a traeger guy so there's a
lot of things to love about
justin tucker the ravens place kicker
who joins us on the program
good morning justin how are you i'm
doing well thanks for uh that was quite
the intro
much appreciated especially with the uh
the hair thing yeah i
actually spent some time on it this
morning do you do your hair before again
uh before the coved era
it was it was a consideration but now
i'm kind of just let the beard
go and uh i haven't got a haircut in
uh quite a while now because i'm trying
to avoid close contacts with as
you know many people as possible so um
i mean yeah like about it you know about
a year ago i was thinking okay well i
mean if i'm standing next to
morgan and sam and randy during the
national anthem you know like those are
sweet pictures that we want to have
so i've got to make sure that the wig is
tight but
this this year not really not really
that as concerned
explain to me if i've never kicked a
field goal before
and you wanted to teach me how to kick a
field goal
where do we start i think
uh you got to start with the
probably the most important principle in
in in all sports that involve
a ball keep your eye on the ball um you
know it's
it's a common theme in baseball uh
tennis
soccer football um
so what i said the other night after the
game
to just trying to keep it as simple as
possible uh
in the moments where so many things can
be going through your head
um you just gotta see the ball to kick
the ball
um but you could kick blindfolds it
starts as simple as that you could kick
blindfold
right i don't know if i could kick
blindfolded with
nearly as much uh confidence or
and or accuracy and power uh
as if i'm not blindfolded but um you
know i i know it i know it's possible
i've seen pat mack if he hit like a
40-something yarder uh
you know set a guinness world record
several years ago kicking blindfolded so
uh you know i i'll leave that i'll leave
the trick shots to the guys who are who
are better at those
wait a minute that's the guinness record
the 40 yards
i'm it's 40 something and i'm pretty
sure pat has the record so
uh you know shout out to pat mcafee and
uh you know
always doing it for the brand but i'm
pretty sure he has a guinness world
record
why don't you go out this afternoon when
this is over with and just
blow him out of the books i mean come on
it's a little snowy uh out here and wait
you don't have a practice
indoor practice facility oh well that's
no fun it's not you know i mean
if it's pouring down snow you gotta like
you know get out in it so
i still like your chances even in the
snow
explain to me how dion sanders became
your
i don't know idol is that fair to say
he's definitely one of
he was definitely one of my favorite
players uh growing up as a
as a little guy so i uh grew up in
austin texas and
my family would always watch the cowboys
on sunday afternoons
and uh i just love like the swag and
like this you know the
the the attitude that that prime brought
to the game
i think uh everybody can appreciate that
about prime so
um yeah when i was in like
first second third grade we'd play
football at recess and i would always
have
like my cowboys do-rag bandana
tied up and i would i would always play
defense so like i
i uh would
try to try to pick off as many passes i
could return as many punts as i could
uh in that 30 minute recess break and
then hit the water fountain
on the way in like it was like it was
nobody's business but but what happens
though
you get to the point where you you're a
kicker
like is it does it feel like it's a
demotion that you
you know defensive back or maybe you
want to play wide receiver
and then you're a kicker and you know
how
the other players are going to label you
or at least see you're a
kicker how did you feel no
not at all uh that was never a
concern or a consideration of mine um
i mean maybe maybe i'm wired a little
different but i was never really
concerned about
any of my teammates uh or
coaches viewing me differently because
of the position i play like that's
to me that's one of the coolest things
about the sport of football is you have
so many different
types of athletes uh probably the widest
array of
types of athletes uh on the field at any
given time
uh compared to any other sport so you
know and
in basketball it's you know in all
likelihood you're you know it's
taller athletes um and and
oh he froze up something he never does
on the field
or he's making us think about his
comments well i know i he had me because
i'm going okay
all right all right his last comment was
that let me see
anyone else wait you froze up you you
yeah i don't know what the deal is i'm
in my basement right next to the modem i
should have
pretty good wi-fi what's in the basement
uh so this is this is kind of our
catch-all room right now a previous
homeowner used this room as his office
i don't really have uh much practical
use for
uh your traditional office but right now
we've got you know just like a
sofa in here and then um let's see i got
my
my guitar's got an amp that's that's not
my drum set
that's uh my my four-year-old son's drum
set oh we got a um
just like a tv on the ground a uh
trampoline
what can you play on the guitar what can
you play
uh i mean i can carry a tune i'm not
really no you can
sing i know that can you fire us can you
fire up the amp there
uh i i i could i mean
you guys you really want me to yeah
let's fire it up here i know you can
sing but let's
let's i you know i just froze the kicker
you're never supposed to freeze the
kicker and i just froze
justin tucker and he's going to come
through here
now once again he a full reset as we
like to say in the business the ravens
eight and five
and uh right now half game back the wild
card number three dolphins in the tie
breaking department justin tucker
who is a future hall of famer joining us
on the program
from his basement with his guitar all
right let me see
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's all i got for you then
what's your go to
what's your go uh what's your two is uh
you know i'm not really uh
i'm more of like a rhythm like kind of
uh rhythm kind of guitarist and then uh
you know i try to uh rip some sweet
vocals over that but um
i mean like i like i like 80s hair metal
type of stuff uh
you know and then i like uh like third
eye blind like
post you know post grunge like 90s era
like nirvana type of stuff
okay uh if you had a walk-up song when
you went out
to kick what would you pick
that's a tough one um
off the top of my head maybe hungry like
the wolf you know because we got the
whole wolf pack out there
morgan cox sam cook and myself uh
i mean plus that song is just like not
many people pick
duran duran is their walk-up song but uh
well done by you does hardball ever say
anything to you before you go out for
a potential game-winning kick
typically no one says anything to me
um and i kind of i kind of prefer it
that way
i mean i'm kind of in i'm kind of in my
own little world for
you know the the 30 some odd seconds
leading up to a um you know especially
an important kick like at the end of the
game
uh i kind of just seem on alone with my
thoughts
and kind of getting myself focused and
in the zone if you will and then
um every once in a while someone will
come in come up to me and say something
and then i
i usually forget whatever it was that
they said
immediately and then you know just go
out there and
try my best to make the kick but uh no
if
if anybody is going to say something to
me it's usually um
randy brown or kicking coach he'll it
won't be like right before the kick but
it'll be
you know first or second down and he'll
you know he'll say uh uh
it's usually just like nuts and bolts
type of stuff it's like all right we got
a
pretty significant right to left win
just play your play that ball in the
right third right quarter let it come
back and uh
just hit your ball ma'am and it's uh
you know really nothing uh too
you know revolutionary by any means but
uh you know just just hearing
something as simple as that kind of help
reminds me not to
overthink it not to get too um
emotionally attached to whatever's
happening
or whatever will happen uh after my foot
hits the ball the only
the only thing that really matters is
the 1.3 seconds between
when morgan throws it back when sam
spots it and when i kick it and it's
just
you know seeing the ball and hitting the
ball you have six career tackles
what's the best one
um because mcafee used to try to blow
people up
do you blow people i would say no i
would say none of them because if i'm
having to make a tackle that's
that's usually indicative of i didn't
kick the ball well enough
to ensure that the return uh
the returner was stopped inside the 20
or 25 so
um no you know what i like come to think
of it i did i had one that was kind of
sweet so
um in pittsburgh on uh
uh playing the nighttime prime game
uh prime time game a couple years back i
squibbed one down toward the open end of
the stadium
and uh the returner um
kind of muffed the ball down there at
the goal line and
uh the timing of the return was all
thrown off and our coverage team was
like cert had surrounded him inside the
five yard line and somehow he squeezed
out of there bounced it
and i tackled the guy at the nine yard
line so
uh typically when your kicker's making
tackles it's at like the 30 35 yard line
and it's after or or
he's not making a tackle and the guy's
you know running past him like forrest
gump
like all the way through the end zone
and through the tunnel at the other end
of the stadium which is not good but
you know every once in a while i i
happen to have a tackle inside the
10-yard line so i feel like that one
i like it that one's probably pretty
good uh when
what's the uh one time the the worst
beating you got
after kicking a game-winning field goal
because like you know sometimes we look
at those kickers and everybody wants to
say congratulations did you have one
where you go guys stop it hurts
uh i mean yeah i'm not built like most
of my teammates
you know i'm i'm probably pound for
pound like the smallest guy on the team
even though in like regular normal
society if you want to call it that i'm
like uh you know
i mean i'm 6'1 183 so i'm not like a
super little guy by any means but in the
football world yeah i am
uh let's see like at texas
uh when we played texas a m on
thanksgiving night my senior year
kicked the game winner and uh kind of
started running towards our sideline
like this
and then i see like our sideline is just
emptying
the entire team is running out toward
midfield where
where you know we're where we're all at
and uh kenny vaccaro
uh outstanding professional safety
now uh an outstanding safety then
he is running full speed with a look in
his eye
like i'm taking this guy down and uh he
horse caller tackles me i'm at the
bottom of a dog pile and thankfully i
didn't
shred both of my knees or anything else
for that matter
but i remember like being at the bottom
of the pile
just in pain and also
very happy that we had just made the
game winning kit
but uh i like i i remember coming up
from the pile
just like gasping for air i had like
blood coming out of my nose
[Music]
but i mean hey it's all
in a in a kind of crazy way you know
like that stuff those experiences are
why you play the game you know
celebrating with your teammates
with absolute reckless abandon is one of
the
greatest things about playing you know
playing a team sport and
winning in big moments it's great to
talk to you
and uh congrats on the success so far
and uh
hopefully you get into the postseason to
make some more of those
game-winning kicks but uh thanks for
joining us uh justin and uh thanks for
playing along
literally playing along with us of
course yeah and thanks for having me dan
that's
uh justin tucker just turned 31 he's
going to be kicking for
quite some time and he doesn't miss